Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Und was ist so dein edler Zweck?
Der ist geheim.
Ja, in der letzten Woche musstest du ja ganz schnell weg und ich hab mit Thomas noch über Netzneutralität gesprochen. Ja, was gab's denn noch so zu erzählen?
Nelly Cruz hat sich ja dann noch mit LaQuadratur, du nett und netzpolitik.org angelegt, weil dort Unwahrheiten behauptet würden. Ich weiß nicht, du hast die Tweets da mal rausgesucht. Was gab's da schönes?
Ja, sie hat dann getwittert, dass BOS, LaQuadratur und Etnetspolitik europäische Zivilisten verbreitet sind. Sieht man ja, was da rauskommt.
Ja, also Nelly Cruz ist da offensichtlich sehr, sehr fehlgeleitet. Aber wir haben noch ein bisschen andere Themen, die, weil ich gestern so früh abgehauen bin, ja sogar vor Sendungsende, wo ich mich nochmal entschuldigen möchte, die dann hinten runtergefallen sind. Und zwar sind das eher so die Kleinmeldungen. Bei der Telekom, bei Orange und bei Telefonica gab es eine Razzia von der EU, von den Wettbewerbshütern. Zwar geht es dabei darum, wir haben das ja in Logbuch Netzpolitik 41, der Sonderfolge von den Dresdner Datenspuren, schon so mal ausführlich besprochen, dass die Telekom dort sitzt und den Nutzern Internet bringt und von den Nutzern dafür Geld haben möchte. Gleichzeitig möchte die Telekom aber auch Geld von den Online-Anbietern, zum Beispiel YouTube, haben, dafür, dass es YouTube zu den Nutzern bringt. Sie sitzen da auf der Brücke, wieder treu unter der Brücke und wollen in beide Richtungen kassieren. Und natürlich wollen die Online-Anbieter, zum Beispiel YouTube, dann nicht an die Telekom zahlen. Und die technischen Gegebenheiten sehen so aus, dass die beiden eben über sogenannte Backbones verbunden sind. Und diese Backbones werden wiederum von anderen Firmen betrieben. Eine Firma, die sich dafür bekannt ist, sich mit den europäischen Internet-Anbietern zu streiten, ist die Firma Kogent. Und was da üblicherweise, macht man zwischen zwei Internet-Anbietern, ein Peering nur dann, wenn der Traffic in beide Richtungen ungefähr ähnlich stark ist. Wenn man sagt, meine Nutzer hier, meine Telekom-Nutzer wollen ungefähr gleich oft sich mit, was weiß ich, O2-Benutzern verbinden, wie umgekehrt und deswegen stecken wir einfach ein Kabel und routen das inzwischen und haben beide was davon. Wenn es einen stärkeren Traffic in eine Richtung gibt, dann wird üblicherweise derjenige, der da mehr macht. Und finde ich also auch nicht gut, nennt sich Transit. Das ist technisch gesehen auch Peering, der Unterschied ist nur, dass es bezahlt wird. Und jetzt sagt Cogen natürlich, naja, hey, wir wollen eigentlich entgeltlos durchgeleitet werden zu euren Nutzern, liebe Telekom, liebe Orange, liebe Telefonica. Und es kann ja nicht sein, dass eure ganzen Nutzer YouTube gucken wollen und wir dann auch noch dafür zahlen müssen. Und andere Seiten sagen halt Telekom, Orange und Telefonica, nö, wenn hier irgendwas ausgebaut wird, wollen wir, dass ihr euch daran beteiligt und wir zahlen euch keinen Cent dafür. Das heißt letztendlich hindern wir unsere Nutzer daran, einen vernünftigen Zugang zu euren Angeboten zu bekommen. Und das hat jetzt dazu geführt, dass ein paar Fahnder der EU-Kommission letzte Woche bei Telekom, Orange, Frankreich und Telefonica, Telefonica der spanischen Firma, der in Deutschland auch O2 gehört, einmarschiert sind, um den Verdacht zu untersuchen, dass sie ihre marktbeherrschende Stellung ausnutzen. Da gab es irgendwie schon 2005 mal Streit drüber, irgendwie zwischen Orange und Cogen. Da hat Orange sogar mal im Streit das ganze Kabel abgeschnitten, wahrscheinlich rausgestöpselt oder so. Und 2010 gab es da auch schon mal ein Wettbewerbsverfahren, das wurde aber irgendwie eingestellt. Also der Streit ist da relativ stark. Und man sieht, dass die Telekom eben, das war ja das, was wir immer betont haben, nicht nur in Richtung der Nutzer irgendwie da Einschränkungen vornehmen will, um mehr Geld zu kassieren, sondern eben auch in Richtung der Anbieter. Und das ist ja genau das Problem, was wir nicht haben wollen im Sinne der Netzneutralität, dass wir jetzt also, wir haben gerade Nelly Cruz angesprochen. Man könnte jetzt hoffen, dass sie diese Angelegenheit da mit aller Schärfe verfolgt. Das wäre zumindest zu...
Nelly Cruz sagt ja, we respect everyone's freedom. Nur mit Netzneutralität hat freedom halt noch nicht ganz so viel zu tun. Kann man immer sagen, in drei Sprachen übrigens, das ist das europäische Moment, auch bei ihr in Tweets.
Setzte sie jeden Tweet in drei Sprachen ab? Nur die wichtigen?
Ja, nur die ganz wichtigen.
Französisch ist noch eine Sprache.
Das ist so eine Kartell-Geschichte.
Ja, Kartell, genau, da gab es ja diese schöne Sache, weil bei netzpolitik.org dann geschrieben wurde, wegen Kartell.
Genau, den wurden rechtliche Konsequenzen von der Telekom angedroht, weil sie Kartell in der Überschrift hatten. Die haben das dann, weil sie keine Lust hatten auf die rechtliche Auseinandersetzung, haben dann dort marktbeherrschende Stellung aus Kartell gemacht.
Was in dem Fall dann auch richtig gewesen wäre, also was auch richtig war. Es geht explizit nicht um die Bildung eines Wirtschaftskartells zwischen jetzt, also Kartell hieß ja das Telefoniker Orange und T-Mobile, Telekom, meine Güte.
Sich absprechen und einen Kartell bilden.
Sich absprechen und sagen, wir zahlen an diese Co-Gent nicht und drücken die irgendwie raus. Diese Absprache scheint es aber nicht zu geben, sondern das ist, wie es leider so ist, für alle drei marktbeherrschenden Unternehmen einfach naheliegende das genau so zu machen. Das heißt, sie brauchen sich da gar nicht abzusprechen.
De facto Kartell.
Ja, marktbeherrschende Stellung, die sie alle drei ausnutzen, unabhängig voneinander, ohne sich abgesprochen zu haben. Genauso scheiße.
Und was haben die da gefunden bei der Razzia? Weiß man das?
Gar nichts. Die haben jetzt erst mal nur geguckt. Durch die Razzia wurde also bekannt, dass es da eine Untersuchung gibt. Und jetzt müssen die, wenn die fahren da eben zusehen oder auch nicht, sich überlegen, was sie da machen. Es wäre schön, wenn da mal... Das sind halt so genau die Streitereien und die wirtschaftlichen Auseinandersetzungen, die du halt in einer zukunftsgewandten digitalen Gesellschaft einfach nicht haben möchtest. Du möchtest einfach Netz haben. Das ist eine Infrastruktur, die für alle da ist. Die soll vernünftig umgesetzt werden für alle. Und damit wäre es schön. Aber dadurch, dass eben an jeder Stelle dieser Infrastruktur irgendwelche Vögel sitzen mit kommerziellen Interessen...
Die sagen, ich stecke das Kabel da nicht rein, weil ich will hier Geld für haben.
Ich will da Geld für haben, ja. Und da sieht man also relativ offensichtlich, wie dieser gesamte Markt, der es ja alles regeln wird, da einfach zum Schaden und zum Nachteil der Nutzer und der Gesellschaft funktioniert. Was ist noch passiert? Genau, in der letzten Woche, wir sind immer noch in der letzten Woche, wurde dann auch die Meldung bekannt, dass Hadopi, also die Behörde, die in Frankreich gegen Falsch-Hero vorgeht, jetzt langsam abgewickelt werden soll.
Das ist diese Three-Strikes-Geschichte. Also du kriegst da Abmahnungen und irgendwann drehen sie dir das Internet ab. Das war das doch ursprünglich mal.
Genau, hat aber irgendwie, also gesetzlich ist das so, hat auch schon ein paar Millionen verschlungen, hat aber glaube ich bis jetzt nicht einen einzigen, oder einen einzigen Menschen jemals irgendwie mit Sanktionen belegt. Und das war ja so dieser große Fail. Also es war klar, diese ganze grundrechtliche Geschichte war ein Riesenproblem. Und also den Leuten das Internet abzudrehen. Und jetzt sind ja in Frankreich auch, es gibt jetzt eine andere Regierung, die Sozialisten waren ja immer dagegen und schreiten jetzt auch zu Tat und geben bekannt, ja, dieses ganze Hadopi wickeln wir jetzt ab und unsere Gesetze sollen in Zukunft so aussehen, dass wir keine Netzsperren oder keine Netzsperren mehr haben für Leute, die irgendwie zu oft beim Downloaden erwischt wurden. Stattdessen wollen wir die Strafen höchstens bei, also wollen wir so höchstens 1500 Euro Strafe pro Download einführen, um das ganze Grundrechts schonen zu machen. Im wiederholten Fall dann 3000 Euro, also das ist ja ein ganz sozialistischer Ansatz hier.
Das sind so ungefähr die Größenordnungen, die auch hier durch die Abmahnindustrie eigentlich so rausgehauen werden, oder?
Geht das echt bis zu 3000 Euro? Also was ich gesehen habe, waren meistens so noch nicht bei 1,5, also so 1,2, habe ich mal gesehen. Du hast ja öfter mal welche gesehen, was ist da so der Wert, den du so...
Ja, das hat sie alles so im 1000er, 1400, je nachdem. Also ich habe aber keine Ahnung, wenn sie dich erwischen, wenn du ganz, ganz viele Sachen runterlädst. Das waren ja immer diese Abmahnungen, die ich gesehen habe, waren immer Dinge, die sich auf einen Film oder auf ein Album bezogen haben. Ich habe noch nie eine Abmahnung gesehen, die jetzt so sagt, und dann hast du irgendwie die Top 100 runtergeladen.
Wobei ja auch in Deutschland die Abmahnung immer nicht für das Runterladen, sondern für das Anbieten ist und da ist genau der Trick dann bei diesem Hadopi, die sagen, naja aber für die Anbieter, den wollen wir natürlich weiterhin bis zu ein Jahr Sperre geben. Und es ist so ein bisschen unklar, ob sie da jetzt von kommerziellen Anbietern sprechen, die irgendwie, was weiß ich, also ich meine, wenn ich kommerziell Urheberrechtsverletzungen betreibe, dann habe ich meine Server eh nicht in Frankreich stehen und dann können die mir da eh nicht irgendwie…
Also so Streaming-Dienste, was meinen sie da?
Ja, so würde ich es jetzt verstehen, aber wir wissen ja, dass allein schon in Deutschland die Abmahnung genau dadurch funktioniert.
Dass sie sagen, es ist gewerblich, auch wenn du nur ein Album hochgeladen hast.
Es ist gewerblich.
Ohne kommerzielles Interesse.
Genau, ohne kommerzielles Interesse bist du in einem Torrent-Schwarm, du bist eigentlich zum Zweck darin, runterzuladen, aber aufgrund des Peer-to-Peer-Protokolls lädst du auch gleichzeitig an andere und dann wird gesagt, ja, also hast du an andere geliefert. Da hingen tausend Leute in dem Torrent-Schwarm, also war das gewerbliches Ausmaß, also nicht gewerbliche Absicht, sondern gewerbliches Ausmaß, lautet ja die Definition. Und da fällt eben jeder drunter, der eigentlich in so einem Torrent-Schwarm ist. Und damit vielen Dank, herzlichen Glückwunsch, hier ist die Rechnung.
Ok, da wird es spannend, was da weiter passiert und wie sich das in Frankreich entwickelt, nachdem jetzt Hadopi weg ist. Also wie gesagt, Three Strikes ist raus. Gibt es das noch in anderen Ländern?
Naja, Three Strikes ist eben für Anbieter. Ich halte das eher für eine Nullnummer, was da in Frankreich jetzt gerade gemeldet wird. Vielleicht eine schöne Nachricht haben wir noch von unseren Freunden.
Sollte es ja auch geben, schöne Nachrichten.
Es gibt schöne Nachrichten, wir haben es ja vorletztes Mal noch beschwert. Die C3S, die Cultural Commons Collecting Society. Ich denke da immer an Photoshop, wenn ich C3S sehe, aber das ist doch die CS3 und das ist doch total outdated. Hol dir mal hier CS6. Wir hatten ja schon vor einigen Folgen den Dani Bruder bei uns und jetzt geht es in die Crowdfunding-Phase. Sie haben die Schwelle bei 50.000 Euro, das heißt, sie brauchen mindestens 50.000. Ihr Ziel liegt eher so bei 200.000, ab 100.000 können sie ihr Ziel dann da komfortabel weiterverfolgen.
Und just in diesem Moment haben sie 17.290.
Genau. 241 Supporter haben sie schon, 75 Tage läuft das noch und man kann da also mit funden. Und ich glaube, so ab 50 Euro bekommt man dann jeweils auch einen Genossenschaftsanteil. Man kann aber auch einfach so spenden. Man kann so ab 10 Euro, 30 Euro, 35 Euro, 75 Euro, da gibt es dann auch irgendwie Supportershirt und einen Workshop mit Lucy van Org oder so wie Tim Renner oder was für teureres Supporting. Also da kann man sogar irgendwie auch im Prinzip so sehr angenehme Belohnungen bekommen. Also wer das verfolgen möchte, sollte da jetzt mitmachen. Außerdem brauchen sie auch noch ihre 3000 Mieter.
Wie ist das Prinzip ganz einfach erklärt? Also wie ist das Prinzip von der C3S?
Sie wollen eine freiere, also der Unterschied ist ja eigentlich, dass bei der GEMA verkaufst du deine gesamte Person und all deine Werke und lässt dich von denen vertreten. Die C3S will genau dieses Problem der GEMA lösen und sagen, wir können, was weiß ich bei uns, kannst du einzelne Stücke vertreten lassen. Wir sind quasi die freiere, offenere, basisdemokratischere Vertretung, Künstlervertretung und nicht so von oben herunter zum Nachteil der kleineren Künstler organisierter Laden wie die GEMA.
Genau, das sehe ich hier auch. Also alle Musiker gegen volles Stimmenrecht und Creative Commons ist möglich und es soll eben nicht so ein Apparat sein, den alle hassen.
Genau, sie wollen der Apparat sein, den alle lieben. Wer da, wie gesagt, kann man noch mal reinhören, unser Gespräch mit Danny Bruder, verlinke ich auch noch mal. Und jetzt wäre also der Punkt da, jetzt ist die heiße Phase bei der C3S, mit Crowdfunding und mit Mitglied werden. Das ist die Empfehlung.
Dann haben wir doch sicher noch ein paar schlechte Nachrichten. Unser aller Innenminister ist ja unterwegs gewesen, was da passiert.
Nein, schlechte Nachrichten ist untertrieben. Ich habe es ja in der letzten Folge schon angekündigt, dass er jetzt da hinfährt und Obama empfängt ihn ja nicht. Also unser Innenminister fliegt in die USA.
Aber der Joe Biden hat mich ja...
Der Joe Biden? Ich habe ja die Gelegenheit gehabt. Man sieht, dass die Amerikaner das sehr ernst nehmen. Der Joe Biden hat mich empfangen. Das ist der Vizepräsident. Ja, da freut sich natürlich so ein kleiner Provinzpfosten wie Friedrich. Fliegt in die USA, kommt zurück und sagt, fürchtet euch nicht, ist alles in Ordnung. Oder? So ungefähr war die... Er hat gesagt, das ist alles völlig legal, was die Amerikaner da machen.
Und da gab es ein schönes Interview, oder? Das ist alles legal vor Gerichten, hat er gesagt. Und dann sagt er, vor amerikanischen Gerichten, ja, aber Verfassungsgericht ist auch konform, dann rät Richard darauf.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung. Er sagt ja, er sagt, das wäre legal. Und das Schöne ist ja dann, dass er von einem edlen Zweck spricht. Von einem edlen Zweck, mit dem das alles betrieben wird.
Der edle Zweck, Menschenleben zu retten vor Terror-Massenvernichtungswaffen. Das ist ja immer dieser Dreiklang, den die innere Sicherheit immer benutzt, ist ja Terror, Massenvernichtungswaffen und organisierte Kriminalität. Das ist ja so, dass damit rechtfertigen sie, dass halt millionenfach alles abgeschnorchelt wird. Das ist auch interessant, dass in jedem Interview, mit dieser Dreiklang kommt er vor.
Der Tritonus. Der Tritonus der inneren Sicherheit. Interessant ist, Kinderpornografie ist da irgendwie nicht mehr. Das fällt dann unter organisierte Kriminalität oder was?
Ja, das fällt hier wahrscheinlich raus, weil es in Deutschland aber nicht geklappt hat.
So, und dann genau, der edle Zweck. Das war ja ZDF Morgenmagazin. Da stellt er sich hin und sagt, die Amerikaner haben ihm versichert, dass sie 45 Terrorakte dadurch verhindert haben. Ich dachte, weltweit, und 25 in Europa, genau. 45 weltweit, 25 in Europa und 5 in Deutschland haben die Amerikaner ihm versichert. Und was war dann die Nachfrage? Ja, sag mal welche.
Genau, dann hat er gesagt, ah, irgendwie, da hat er nicht richtig drauf geantwortet und dann ist ihm sein Pressesprecher in den Rücken gefallen. Da hat er gesagt, sind doch nur zwei Sauerland und die Düsseldorf Gruppe. Sauerland, da war doch der CIA auch dabei. Das ist auch interessant, wenn dann die NSA CIA-Beteiligungen aufdeckt.
Er hat dann irgendwie gesagt, fünf in Deutschland, und dann kam es irgendwie, dann wurde nachgefragt und dann hat er gesagt, ja, fünf, sechs, vielleicht waren es auch fünf, vielleicht fünf, vielleicht mehr, vielleicht waren es weniger.
Genau, und da kann eben also nicht stattgefundene Anschläge, könnte man halt auch nicht so gut beziffern. Und sein Sprecher meinte das ganze Jahr, diese anderen drei, die waren noch gar nicht so im Vorbereitungsstatus, also die haben doch nicht in der Garage irgendwelche Düngergeschichten irgendwie gesammelt. Aber die haben das irgendwie vorgehabt, aber das kann man halt nicht so genau sagen. Und das ist ja auch alles geheim. Also das ist nicht, die Amerikaner haben gesagt, es ist geheim, deswegen können wir darüber auch nicht reden.
Ja, keine Ahnung, also das ist ja eine totale Luftnummer. Und dann musste er am Anfang dieser Woche im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium da Rede und Antwort stehen.
Genau, am Dienstag. Da musste er ins parlamentarische Kontrollgremium. Das sind die, die die Geheimdienste kontrollieren. Wie war das denn, den Spruch hatte ich vorher gelesen. Das sind wie Pilze, man lässt sie im Dunkeln und füttert sie mit Scheiße. Ein nicht sehr mächtiges Gremium, die Geheimdienste zu kontrollieren. Dort hat er auch nicht viel mehr gesagt, als er sowieso schon in den...
Er hat weniger gesagt. Er hat nämlich keine Zahlen mehr genannt. Das weiß ich im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium, hat er dann keine Zahlen mehr genannt.
Genau, und seine Strategie ist ja, es ist ein Jahr, wir warten jetzt auf die Deklassifizierung der Akten durch die Amerikaner.
Das war ja der Erfolg, den er verkauft hat. Er ist ja nach Hause gegangen und hat gesagt, die nehmen das ernst, die verfolgen einen edlen Zweck, das ist alles in Ordnung, alles legal, was totaler Bullshit ist.
Ganz klar gemacht, hat er das klar gemacht, mit aller Deutlichkeit. Und die verfolgen einen edlen Zweck und sie müssen es jetzt erst mal deklassifizieren. Interessant sprachlich fand ich, der Mann redet nur im Konjunktiv die ganze Zeit. Was der Snowden sagt hätte, wäre, könnte, der tut so, als seien diese Dinger, als seien doch nicht bestätigt, dass diese Folien echt sind, obwohl nicht mal der NSA das dementiert.
Stimmt. Also selbst die US-Regierung hat ja eigentlich, sie hat es niemals dementiert. NSA, niemand hat es jemals dementiert. Und die US-Regierung hat ja sogar den Zugriff auf diese Dokumente über das Internet gesperrt, mit der Begründung, dass sie ja immer noch geheim sind. Das heißt, dadurch haben sie es absolut, also haben sie sie natürlich schon bestätigt. Und dass sie sagen, wir deklassifizieren jetzt Dokumente, die ohnehin schon offen im Internet sind.
Und darauf wartet dann der Friedrich.
Darauf wartet der Friedrich jetzt, weil dann darf er nämlich erst sie sich angucken. Dann darf er das auch erst. Im Moment sind die ja geheim, darf der ja gar nicht gucken. Und darauf wartet er jetzt noch. Und das verkauft er jetzt in Deutschland als Erfolg, dass er also den Amerikanern abgerungen hat, dass sie interne Dokumente deklassifizieren.
Und dass dieses Geheimabkommen von irgendwann in den 60er Jahren, was aber seit 1990 auch nicht mehr eingesetzt oder umgesetzt wird, dass man das jetzt auch aufhört.
Ja, weil es da schon einen Nachfolger von gibt.
Ja, also er kam mit leeren Händen zurück und hat sich dann noch weiter verstiegen nach dem Sitzung im Kontrollgremium. Hat er nämlich gesagt, also erstens ist Sicherheit ein super Grundrecht. Übrigens nicht seine Erfindung, sondern von Otto Schilli. Das super Grundrecht, was eigentlich alle anderen schlägt. Das ist so wie die Joker-Karte in deinem Kartenspiel, wo du sagen kannst, und ihr habt Sicherheit, zack, Menschenwürde weg. Also hat sie als Jurist auch da ganz toll hervorgetan. Und hat dann gesagt, ihr müsst alle verschlüsseln und Virenscanner benutzen. Und das Thema will er ganz stark voranbringen, zusammen mit der Kanzlerin, die sich in dem ganzen Ding übrigens sehr bedeckt hält. Das ist auch spannend zu beobachten, wie sie immer schön im Hintergrund, bloß nicht sich da...
Ja, hat schon seinen Grund, warum der Friedrich dahingefahren ist und nicht sie. Genau, jetzt kommt es spannend. Jetzt wird die SPD langsam laut. Die SPD wird laut. Steinbrück sagt sogar, naja, das ist gesagt indirekt, dass Frau Merkel ihren Amtseid verletzt hat. Also er sagt, Frau Merkel hat als Kanzlerin den Amtseid geschworen, Schaden vom deutschen Volke abzuwenden. Jetzt kommt heraus, dass Grundrechte der deutschen Bürger massiv verletzt werden, wurden also Schaden vom Volke abzuwenden. Das stelle ich mir anders vor. Interessant ist, dass... also jetzt so, das finde ich mal, finde ich ja schon mal schön, finde ich ja schon mal schön, dass... also, ich meine, gut, es ist halt...
Aber hättest du die SPD für glaubwürdig, solange sie nicht die Vorratsdatenspeicherung abschießen? Also ich meine, das ist doch der springende Punkt.
Genau.
Wenn sie jetzt konsequent werden, wenn sie sagen, okay, mit uns ist Vorratsdatenspeicherung in keinster Weise, auch nicht mit, machen wir nur einen Monat oder sonst wie oder noch mal drüber reden und irgendwelche komischen Kompromissformeln, sondern die einzige glaubwürdige Aktion wäre doch, von der SPD zu sagen, Vorratsdatenspeicherung weg.
Sie haben ja noch nicht einmal, noch nicht einmal, wie die CDU die Vorratsdatenspeicherung umbenannt, in Mindestspeicherfristen für Telekommunikationsdaten. Noch nicht einmal das, ja.
Das sind nur Metadaten, die da gespeichert werden.
Also die SPD und spannender Hinweis, Steinmeier müsste eigentlich auch von den Sachen gewusst haben. Das heißt, man muss den Steinmeier jetzt erstmal irgendwo in den Keller sperren.
Genau, weil Steinmeier war ja Kanzleramtsminister und da in dieser Rolle eben zuständig für die Geheimdienste. Was heute Pofalla ist, der sich übrigens auch sehr bedeckt hält. Und die Kanzlerin schaut ja gar nicht in diese Geheimdienstdinger rein. Das macht der Pofalla, also Frau Präsidentin setzt sich schön ab. Aber diesem Steinmeier ist natürlich auch so, denen sind die Hände gebunden, der SPD. Da ist wenig Luft drin, weil sie sich ja selber. Und Steinmeier, da kommt gleich so ein Kurnas mit hoch, den man irgendwie im Hintergrund noch hat. Und da ist die SPD deswegen vorsichtig. Aber ich glaube, der einzige Weg, wie die SPD das richtig nutzen könnte für die Wähler, ist eben zu sagen Vorratsdatenspeicherung weg. Und dann sind sie glaubwürdig und dann können sie auch voll attackieren.
Aber dann können sie keine große Koalition mit der CDU machen.
Genau. Und dann fehlt die Macht, alternative Rot-Rot-Grün. Also von dem her wird das nicht passieren wahrscheinlich, ne? Schade eigentlich.
Unglaublich. Spannend ist, auf einmal springt Bild rein, das war dann, glaube ich, am Montag, wenn ich die Tage jetzt nicht durcheinanderbringe, und sagt, ja übrigens, der BND nutzt die Daten über PRISM seit Jahren mit.
Und dann gestern Abend grätscht MDR Fakt rein und sagt, hey, der BND nutzt auch die PRISM-Software oder Technologie. Und dann kommt heute Morgen noch dazu, dass das deutsche Militär seit 2011 PRISM nutzt und das in Dokumenten der NATO oder irgendwelche Briefings eben dort aufgelistet ist. Geben sie bitte die Informationen an PRISM weiter, das steht da drin. Haben wir alle nichts gewusst. Demisier war ja auch mal Innenminister und so. Wir sind alle von nichts natürlich bislang, aber dementieren es nicht. Also dieses letzte wird nicht dementiert. Das kann schon noch ganz schön gefährlich werden für die, weil sie jetzt immer dieses wir wissen von nichts, wir wissen von nichts, wir wissen es von nichts. Und man weiß ja auch nicht, was Snowden noch so, was für ein Blatt der noch so auf der Hand hat. Ich denke, da kommt noch einiges.
Snowden hat ja jetzt noch mal betont, also das hat er ja schon vor Wochen gemacht, aber es machte in dieser Woche noch mal die Runde, dass Snowden eben sagt, wenn mir was zustößt, dann wird es den USA noch mal richtig leid tun. Ja, das kann natürlich auch ein Bluff sein, ne?
Die Todmann-Maschine, ne? Die sogenannte Todmann, Todter-Mann-Knopf oder sowas. Ne, Todmann, genau. Das ist das, was in der Straßenbahn, der Straßenbahnfahrer, der klickt immer klick, klick, klick, muss immer irgendwie in Aktion bleiben oder irgendwie zeigen, dass er noch lebt. Das Gleiche kann ich natürlich auch bauen, wenn irgendwie Snowden tot, dann liegt alles. Also da gibt, ja, aber ich denke schon, dass er sich abgesichert hat. Obwohl ich, was ich sehr spannend jetzt finde, ist, jetzt hat Snowden ja vorläufiges Asyl in Russland beantragt und Russland sagt aber, hey, solange, wenn du hier Asyl hast, dann darfst du keine schädigenden Veröffentlichungen machen. Das heißt, solange der dann gefangen ist in dieser Bürokratiemühle, wird er nicht viel veröffentlichen können.
Ich weiß es nicht, ich bin mir, ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, also man kann das ja so spielen. Also ich kann mir das sogar echt so vorstellen, dass Russland sagt, ey, alles klar, den Snowden, der kriegt jetzt bei uns Asyl mit einer Auflage und dann einen Tag später veröffentlicht er irgendwas, dann hat er gegen seine Auflagen verstoßen, da müssen wir ihn leider ausweisen, aber wir weisen den ja nicht in den Tod aus. Das haben sie ja gesagt, wir liefern niemanden in ein Land aus, wo ihm die Todesstrafe droht. Also müssen wir den ausweisen, weil er gegen seine Asylauflagen verstoßen hat und jetzt müssen wir den leider nach Bolivien fliegen. Übrigens, Side note, Bolivien hat jetzt immerhin schon mal eine Entschuldigung empfangen von Spanien.
Und von Frankreich.
Von Frankreich auch schon, ja.
Frankreich war zuerst, ja und Spanien, da hat der Botschafter sich entschuldigt. Das ist unglaublich.
Also diese ganze Sache mit der Präsidentenmaschine, die finde ich ja unglaublich. Ich meine, ich finde das alles unglaublich.
Das ist auf jeden Fall alles unglaublich. Also das ist auf jeden Fall, da kommt noch einiges raus und es gibt ja viele Leute, die hoffen, dass es der Bundesregierung zum Schaden gereicht. Und ich bin gespannt, vielleicht kommt auch raus, dass die Deutschen genau das Gleiche nutzen. Sieht ja jetzt schon so aus. Was gibt es über diesen Hersteller, von dieser Software zu sagen?
Ja, der wurde jetzt ja gerade erst bekannt, Naros heißen die und sie haben ja auch dieses, das ist ganz schön, sie haben ja dieses Logo von Prism, das nutzt quasi, also Naros nutzt dieses Prism-Logo. Ich suche gerade mal den Link, wo habe ich den denn, meine Güte?
Ja, hier habe ich einen.
Naros, ja und die werben also relativ offen für ihr Produkt. Also man stellt schon, genau, Cyber 3.0, Analytics for Cyber Security und das Produkt heißt glaube ich bei denen sogar Prism. Auf jeden Fall haben sie einen, genau Golem war der, bei Golem war der APK. Sie haben auf jeden Fall dieses schöne Logo, ja. Also da weiß man auch, woher der NSA dieses Logo, dieses Prisma von dem Künstler da geklaut hat und sie haben also auf Netzwerkebene, auf semantischer Ebene und auf Nutzer Ebene können sie eben analysieren.
Also das heißt, sie benutzen vom gleichen Hersteller Software, das ist jetzt bekannt.
Also genau, und das sagt die NSA, das sagt die Bildzeitung jetzt, also Bildzeitung jetzt echt eine spannende Rolle. Die Bildzeitung sagt ja dann sogar, übrigens nicht nur kommt der Friedrich nach Hause und er macht einen, also das ist ein historischer Auftritt gewesen, dieses Interview von dem Friedrich in dem Morgenmatzdien im ZDF, das war historisch. Also eine solche Scheiße zu labern, Entschuldigung, ich weiß jetzt in den Kommentaren beschweren sich wieder die Leute, übrigens kann ich dazu noch ganz kurz, sage ich gleich nochmal zu, aber also einen solchen Quatsch dazu machen, eine solche Luftnummer, das ist der größte Witz, den ich in letzten, in vielen Jahren gesehen habe, ist das, was der Friedrich damit seine USA-Reise gemacht hat und er kommt mit absolut leeren Händen nach Hause und beschwichtigt in Deutschland und erzählt einen vom Pferd, dass das alles legal, alles mit guten Dingen, mit rechten Dingen zuginge, erzählt noch einen vom edlen Zweck, ja, und das vom Hintergrund, dass bekannt wurde, dass die USA Institutionen der EU abgehört haben, ja, also es ist ein völliger…
Ich finde, man muss zwischen den Zeilen immer lesen, bei allen Aussagen, auch von Merkel, aber auch von Friedrich, ist immer vom deutschen Boden die Rede, also wenn das auf deutschem Boden passiert, dann ist das nicht akzeptabel, wenn aber das Kabel woanders oder der Server woanders angezapft wird, dann ist das nämlich in Ordnung, heißt das auf gut Deutsch.
Das ist auffallend, wie nennt man das, auffallend spezifisch?
Genau, auffallend spezifisch.
Verdächtig spezifisch.
Ich finde es spannend, dass die Bild-Zeitung jetzt so ein investigatives Ding aufmacht und auch sagt, hey, das geht hier um, da geht es nicht um Metadaten, da wird konkret Inhalte abgegriffen, Inhalte von Kommunikation, weil man hat ja so das Gefühl bei Friedrich, er will das auf so eine Vorratsdatenspeicherebene irgendwie bringen, damit das in Einklang geht mit der deutschen Politik und das stimmt halt einfach nicht, ne?
Also, ja, das stimmt überhaupt nicht und die Bild kommt ja dann sogar noch hin und sagt, das finde ich ja das Spannendste. Also erstmal sagen sie, übrigens hier, BND, seit Jahren Nutznieser dieser Sache, Bundeswehr, spätestens seit 2011 dokumentiert, den Quatsch eingesetzt in Afghanistan, ja? Und dann sagen sie, übrigens, und der Friedrich, der hat da gar nicht mit denen irgendwie großartig darüber gesprochen, dass sie das jetzt sein lassen sollen, sondern der hat die Kooperation sogar noch ausgebaut, ja? Also so steht es in der Bild-Zeitung, die ja bekanntermaßen Wahrheit verkündet, zumindest, wenn sie mal gegen die Regierung ist, weil also, dass die Bild-Zeitung gegen eine CDU-Regierung ballert, das hast du alle zehn Jahre einmal.
Das hält noch, auf jeden Fall, ne?
Das ist wirklich eine krasse Sache. So, und gleichzeitig, was passiert in den USA? Die gehen hin und sagen, ja, wir bauen jetzt einfach mal die Befugnisse des Department of Homeland Security aus. Und das finde ich sehr spannend. Und zwar haben sie gesagt, im Prinzip so, die dürfen da jetzt auch auf alles zugreifen und alles irgendwie, also einmal so Generalvollmacht für Vollüberwachung, so ungefähr, lässt sich das ausdrücken. Jetzt stellt sich die Frage, warum machen die das ausgerechnet zu diesem Zeitpunkt? Und meine Interpretation der Sache ist, sie sehen, also im Prinzip die Debatte, die historische Debatte über Internetüberwachung und Cyberspionage, zumindest unter dem Grundrechtlichen, oder wirklich, die Debatte, die öffentliche historische Debatte über Überwachung, die findet jetzt statt. Einmalig.
Genau, weil wenn man es jetzt mal zuspitzt, ist ein Überwachungsstaat keine Demokratie und wir befinden uns in der Auseinandersetzung, ob wir noch eine Demokratie sind. Kann man davon, also wenn man das mal zugespitzt sieht, wenn millionenfach Grundrechte permanent immer jeden Tag gebrochen werden, dann ist es schwierig, das noch als Demokratie zu bezeichnen. Wir sind jetzt in der Auseinandersetzung, die nicht nur in Deutschland geführt wird, sondern auch in USA und weltweit eigentlich. Und das ist schon eine Zeitenwende, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das ist ein historischer Moment, der jetzt da gerade stattfindet. Und was jetzt am Ende dieser Debatte steht, ist das, was dann in weiteren Jahren eben als akzeptiert, historisch richtig, als Geschichte, als Geschichtsschreibung so stehen wird. Die Debatte wurde damals geführt und sie kam zu diesem und jedem Ergebnis. Und das wird nicht mehr angezweifelt, genauso wie bei anderen richtungsweisenden Entscheidungen. Also da mag es dann noch immer wieder Splitterparteien geben, die dann sich da immer noch gegenwenden, die dann irgendwie zwischen 5 und 11 Prozent irgendwie eventuell bekommen können, aber keine ordentliche Schnitte mehr bekommen. Weil die Debatte ist ja gelaufen. Und selbst so weit wird es nicht kommen, nämlich zum Beispiel Abbau des Sozialstaats. Historische Debatte vor ungefähr zehn Jahren oder wann war das alles so und inzwischen gegeben so. Gibt es keine nennenswerten Beschwerden mehr darüber. Klar wissen alle, dass das falsch ist, dass es scheiße ist. Aber das Thema ist durch und das hat sich erledigt. Und genauso wird es mit dieser Überwachung dann auch sein.
Da hat mir ein Freund, der mit Computern recht wenig zu tun hat und auch mit Verschlüsselung und Überwachung oder so gar nicht, der meinte letztens zu mir, er sei jetzt wieder politisiert, weil er möchte sich nicht von seinen Enkeln vorwerfen lassen, warum habt ihr damals nichts gemacht. Vielleicht dramatisieren wir auch, vielleicht aber auch nicht. Vielleicht hat er auch komplett recht, warum habt ihr damals nichts getan dagegen. Ich bin jetzt volle Kalotte politisiert. Da ist eine Frage, wie kriegen wir noch viel mehr oder wie könnten noch viel mehr Leute oder warum sind eigentlich nur so wenige Leute bislang irgendwie auf der Straße oder politisiert, weil in den Medien ist das ja ein präsentes Thema, was immer auf der Eins steht.
Genau, das Spannende ist, dass die USA jetzt hingehen und die Befugnisse des Homeland Security Departments ausbauen. Daran sieht man, dass die sich jetzt inzwischen sicher fühlen und sagen, alles klar, das läuft in unsere Richtung hier und jetzt wollen wir mal sehen, ob wir das nicht einfach als Rückenwind nehmen können. Jetzt schieben wir noch ein paar Sachen drunter bzw. jetzt legen wir noch was obendrauf. Dann haben wir es nämlich durch, dann wird das nicht nachher in zehn Jahren noch mal skandalisiert werden. Weil im Moment sieht es so aus, als würden wir die öffentliche Debatte gewinnen. Und dann können wir genauso gut noch die ganze Überwachung ausbauen.
Oder man legt vor, um später nur die Sachen, die man noch draufgelegt hat, wieder zurücknehmen zu müssen. Das ist ja auch eine Strategie. Also ich denke, was aber hier so fehlt in der Debatte, und ich glaube, die Debatte kann nur gewonnen werden, wenn man davon sprechen kann, wenn es noch breiter die Leute beschäftigt. Ich habe einen guten Artikel gelesen von Christoph Kappes, der eben gesagt hat, Vertrauen in der Gesellschaft geht dadurch kaputt. Und er meint, das Ganze zieht es eigentlich gar nicht auf so eine sehr politische Ebene, sondern eher auf so eine gesellschaftliche. Wir zerstören unsere Gesellschaft und das, was die Gesellschaft ausmacht mit dieser Komplettüberwachung. Ich finde diesen sehr spannenden und guten Text zum Thema. Und der thematisiert auch, warum juckt es denn jetzt hier auf einmal nur so wenig Leute, weil es irgendwie so abstrakt ist und so technisch. Also den Text.
Was ich noch ein sehr spannendes Thema bei der ganzen Sache finde, ist Wirtschaftsspionage. Also ich meine, wir haben ja schon über den innenpolitischen Tritonus gesprochen. Aber was ist mit…
Ja, das lässt sich jetzt schlecht rechtfertigen. Also die Existenz von Geheimdiensten, das machen wir so, um politische Gegner und Wirtschaftsspionage irgendwie zu betreiben, das kommt dann nicht so gut an.
Ja, aber du hast ja nicht diese riesige Abhörinfrastruktur wegen Gefahr. Das ist natürlich selbstverständlich, da wurde ja in einem Artikel dann auch bei tagesschau.de glaube ich so ein NSA-Direktor zitiert, der schon irgendwie 2000 sagte, wir wären doch blöd, wenn wir nicht die dadurch gewonnenen Erkenntnisse für unsere Interessen nutzen würden. Und das hat er sogar noch ungefähr gesagt, dass das eine moralische Verpflichtung ist. Und da gibt es ja sogar einen Fall jetzt, der dann mal als Beispiel genannt wird bei der Tagesschau. Und zwar das Unternehmen Enercon, deutsches Unternehmen, die irgendwie sehr viel in Forschung investiert haben im Bereich der Windräder. Also es ist ein sehr krasser Forschungszweig, wo immer noch wieder, immer wieder alle paar Jahre bahnbrechende Innovationen geschehen. Wie effizient man so ein Generator-Windrad bauen kann. Und die sind irgendwie in den USA dann auf den Markt gegangen mit Millionen Investitionen und so. Und der Konkurrent hatte genau ihre Technologie, die sie irgendwie geheim entwickelt haben. Und das ist, wir reden da halt nicht mehr von, das muss doch einfach mal klar sein, wir reden hier nicht von irgendwie innerer Sicherheit oder so. Wir reden hier von der Verletzung der Souveränität anderer Staaten untereinander.
Genau, aber ich glaube, dass den Punkt unter diesem Deckmantel von, wir tauschen hier die Daten aus und das ist wichtig und die fünf Terroranschläge, die wir haben verhindern können, wird das eben unter den Tisch fallen gelassen. Aber das sind natürlich Geheimdienste immer schon und ich glaube, das ist auch überhaupt nicht neu, wirtschaftliche Vorteile für das eigene Land versuchen zu ergattern. Also ich glaube, das ist nichts Neues, nur sollte das eigentlich auch ein Grund sein, dagegen vorzugehen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, wir haben ja ein riesen Problem. Genau, da wollte ich noch kurz was zu sagen. In den Kommentaren schreibt dann jemand so, ja, aber wir leben hier in der Demokratie und wenn das den meisten Leuten egal ist, dann ist das eben der demokratische Stand. Also wurde sich dann darüber beschwert, dass ich letztes Mal mich da sehr darüber aufgeregt habe. So, wenn jetzt, sag ich mal, jetzt kommt das ans Licht, wenn das deutsche Volk entscheidet, die Mehrheit interessiert sich jetzt nicht dafür, der geht es am Arsch auf euch, dann ist das ok, dann ist das quasi demokratisch post hoc legitimiert. Das sehe ich ein bisschen anders, weil selbst wenn es allen Deutschen egal wäre, ist es halt eine Verletzung der Souveränität des Staates. Und auch alle demokratisch legitimierten Verfassungen, also irgendwie Völkerrecht und EU-Schater der Grundrechte, deutsche Grundgesetze und so, all das wird ja mit diesen Maßnahmen mit Füßen getreten. Das heißt, alle höchsten demokratischen Regelwerke, die wir uns irgendwie auferlegt haben, werden dadurch verletzt. Es geht also nicht mehr irgendwie um Demokratie, sondern es geht um Angriffe auf die Souveränität von Staaten durch die USA.
Genau, das führt aber eher zu einer Nationaldebatte, die finde ich weniger spannend. Ich finde viel mehr spannend, wir haben Verfassungen, wir haben ein Grundgesetz, wir haben Werte und Freiheitsrechte und Grundrechte und die gilt es zu verteidigen. Nur weil es Leute nicht interessiert, sind diese Werte trotzdem universal und die muss man schützen.
Dafür sind sie auch so da, damit nämlich genau nicht die Demokratie sich selber abschafft. Deswegen gibt es ja dieses Grundgesetz, das sagt, so würde es und so weiter, ein Briefgeheimnis und so weiter. Das sind die Spielregeln, innerhalb derer wir die Demokratie machen und nur mit irgendwelchen riesigen Mehrheiten können wir diese Spielregeln überhaupt ändern, damit nämlich genau nicht auf einmal irgendein Spinner daherkommt, der schafft einen größeren Teil der Bevölkerung hinter sich zu bringen mit irgendeiner völlig kruden These und dann da irgendwie die Demokratie abschafft. Das ist ja die Stabilisierung, der stabilisierende Moment und genau das wird jetzt hier verletzt. Die Fragestellung spielt sich nicht mehr im Rahmen einer demokratischen Debatte ab, sondern im Rahmen des demokratischen Grundgerüstes.
Interessant finde ich dabei die Konstellation, weil hier in Deutschland ist ja immer wehrhafte Demokratie, man wehrt sich gegen Extremisten, was auch immer das ist und das sind ja immer so Feinde, die innerhalb des politischen Lagers sind. Denn jetzt haben wir eine ganz andere Situation, man hat von außen Staaten, die die Grundrechte brechen unter Kollaboration der Regierung und das ist eine ganz andere Situation um eine Verfassung und Verfassungsbrüche, die eben da eindeutig die ganze Zeit passieren, wie man die schützen will. Weil wenn deine Regierung zusammen mit anderen Staaten deine Grundrechte bricht, dann ist die Verfassung eben genauso in Gefahr und die Grundrechte. Also das ist schon eine interessante Konstellation und ich finde es spannend, was jetzt da passiert, wie man Wege findet, dass da politisch mehr noch Druck entsteht. Es gibt Demonstrationen demnächst, das ist eine Sache, am 27. Juli sind Demonstrationen in ganz verschiedenen Städten. Mal gucken, was da, wie viele Leute das auf die Straße bringt. Aber da könnte, vom politischen Druck her finde ich das noch relativ harmlos, angesichts der Härte der Eingriffe, die da passieren.
Ja und ich glaube, wir sind uns da einig, vom politischen Personal brauchen wir in der Angelegenheit nichts mehr zu erwarten. Also was Friedrich da geliefert hat, kann man noch komplett abhaken. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr schwarzer Moment, den wir gerade erleben. Was sich auch daran zeigt, dass ein junger Mann aus Grießheim, der auf Facebook, also hast du das auf Facebook angeschaut?
Ich habe nur die Geschichte mitbekommen, da hat jemand aufgerufen, wir machen ein bisschen Spaziergang an einem Dagger-Komplex. Was ist dieser Dagger-Komplex?
So eine NSA-Einrichtung bei Grießheim.
Genau, die wollten einfach einen Spaziergang machen, mit Kameras und Blumen da außen rum. Da haben sie einfach aufgerufen und auf einmal stehen die Cops vor der Tür.
Sie haben einen Hinweis von der US-Militärpolizei bekommen und dem wollten wir mal nachgehen. Dann sagte er, ich bin auf Facebook nicht der Witzbold und wollte mal was machen, was meinen Freunden gefällt. Deswegen habe ich diesen witzigen Aufruf geschrieben. Woraufhin die Polizei gesagt hat, alles klar, dann gehen wir mal wieder, tschau. Dann klingelt wieder das Telefon und es heißt, ja, schönen guten Tag, könnten Sie mal vorbeikommen, hier ist der Staatsschutz. Ach, wissen Sie was, wir kommen einfach zu Ihnen. Dann steht bei ihm auch noch der Staatsschutz vor der Tür und fragt irgendwie, ob er irgendwie Verbindungen zum Schwarzen Block hätte.
Und dann sagt er, was ist das, das ist gut, sagt er an die Polizei, das hast du auch gelesen, ist schön dokumentiert, glaube ich bei Gutjahr. Er hat die Geschichte recherchiert und die anderen Medien sind dann raufgesprungen. Aber ich finde den Vorgang jetzt, weil der Staatsschutz sagt, du musst das anmelden als Versammlung, das finde ich jetzt nicht so total verrückt. Also wenn ich irgendwo aufrufe, eine Demo zu machen und das ist ja irgendwo Demo-Charakter, wenn ich angesichts der politischen Lage um ein NSA-Komplex rumlaufe, dann hat das einen politischen Charakter, muss man in Deutschland anmelden.
Hat er ja dann auch gemacht und hat aber dann auch darüber berichtet, dass er da vom Staatsschutz Besuch hat. Das finde ich auch richtig. Das muss er auch so machen. End vom Lied war, es sind irgendwie 70 Spaziergänger am Samstag in Grießheim um die Anlage gegangen, vor den Streifenwagen, hinter den Streifenwagen. Dann haben sie irgendwie Lockrufe gemacht, um die Spione…
Die Spitzel rauszuholen.
Die haben aber nicht reagiert. Aber man kann sich ungefähr vorstellen, was da abgelaufen ist. Die USA haben natürlich in ihrem Prison-Filter für Dagger-Komplex. Und haben dann sofort gesehen, der Typ, was macht der da, übersetzt das mal. Okay, der möchte kommen, dann schicken wir mal die deutsche Polizei vorbei. Wir füllen unsere Spionage-Einrichtungen von euren Bürgern bedroht. Bitte schiebt dem einen Riegel vor, schickt da mal euren Staatsschutz vorbei. Du kannst ja nur noch an den Kopf fassen.
Es sieht man aber auch, wie schnell die sich bedroht fühlen. Das ist ja auch ein Learning daraus, wie schnell da ein Riesenapparat angeworfen wird, um so ein paar Leute, die mit so Pub-Kameras vorbeikommen, zu kontrollieren.
Sie können es ja nur mit Prism herausgefunden haben. Der Typ hat keine großartige Gefolgschaft auf Facebook. Und es hat auch ein paar Tage gedauert, bis sie bei ihm vorbeikamen. Das war ja nicht auf irgendeinem großen Blog. Wenn man jetzt sagt, er war auf Nerdcore oder auf netzpolitik.org, dann hätte man jetzt noch sagen können, da scheint eventuell irgendwie. Aber nein, der Typ hatte nichts.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass die in Prism alle Militär und Spionage und was es sich sonst wie relevanten Einrichtungen, wird halt darauf gefiltert, macht ja auch mehr Sinn als auf das Wort Bombe zu filtern. Also, was wahrscheinlich auch machen.
Unglaublich, unglaublich.
Gibt es noch mehr schlechte Nachrichten in dieser Woche?
Ja, ich glaube, das war es jetzt wahrscheinlich zum Überwachungsteil. Wir wissen ja, das andere große Problem, die andere große Sorge, die das Internet immer hat, sind die Sperren. Und da, das war etwas, was ich auch letzte Woche eigentlich schon berichten wollte. Da gibt es also jetzt im Binnenmarkt einen Ausschuss, und der möchte sich um das Problem des illegalen Glücksspiels kümmern.
Das ist schon wieder so ein Schlüsselwort für Achtung, Web-Sperre.
Genau. Und genauso ist es auch. Sie sagen also, ja, wir wollen hier im Binnenmarktausschuss die Geldströme des illegalen Glücksspiels einfrieren. Und dann wollen wir natürlich auch Web-Sperren machen. Und dann haben sie gesagt, da wollen wir uns also überlegen, ob wir das über Black- und Whitelisting machen können. Also, das ist spannend. Blacklisting heißt, ich schreibe eine Liste, wo die verbotenen Seiten drin stehen und sperre sie.
Denen erst zu sperren.
Das heißt, ich lasse alles zu, außer die, die in meiner Liste stehen. Whitelisting heißt, ich verbiete alles und lasse nur zu, was in meiner Liste steht. Wenn ich also jetzt sage, ich möchte einen Whitelist haben für Glücksspiel im Internet, das ist technisch nicht möglich, weil dann müsstest du auf deiner Liste immer das gesamte Internet stehen haben, bis auf die illegalen Glücksspiel-Sachen. Was sie wahrscheinlich meinen, ist, sie wollen so eine Whitelist der Glücksspielseiten machen. Das wiederum geht aber auch nicht, weil du ja nicht automatisch jedes Glücksspiel spielen kannst. Also man merkt, da sind wirklich Experten am Werke. Und es ist ja schon einige Zeit her, dass die EU-Kommission Offenheit niederschreiben lassen, dass Web-Sperren ineffizient sind und dass sie das verstanden haben.
Aber es kommt immer wieder hoch.
Es kommt immer wieder hoch. Und jetzt eben in der Glücksspiel-Thematik im Binnenmarktausschuss. Und die Entscheidung darüber steht dann im September an. Und da sehe ich also so ein Ding. Im Moment hat glaube ich keiner die Energie, sich mit Web-Sperren wegen Glücksspiel auseinanderzusetzen.
Das ist gerade ein bisschen eine andere Thematik. Bei Black- und White-Listing, um vielleicht von dem Thema nochmal wegzukommen, aber ist gerade was Schönes hochgepoppt. Und zwar ist Blacklisting bei PayPal, wenn du Produkte verkaufst, die das Wort Iran im Produkt haben. Da wollte jemand ein Fotoalbum, iranische Wohnzimmer oder iranisches Leben zu Hause verkaufen. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ist verboten, darfst du nicht über PayPal verkaufen. Dann haben die da angerufen und gesagt, was ist denn los? Wir machen hier ein Fotoalbum über iranisches Leben irgendwie. Was wollt ihr? Und dann hat das lange gedauert und dann kamen sie auf die White-List und dürfen als User dann das Wort Iran benutzen in Produkten. Aber generell ist das Wort Iran verboten.
Wenn man das so sieht, kann man beides natürlich kombinieren. Wenn Iran drin ist, sperre, außer es steht auch drin ein Fotoalbum. Das stimmt, das muss man natürlich sagen. Wenn man erst eine Blacklist macht und dann dahinter eine White-List schaltet, dann kann man das so kombinieren, dass es theoretisch ginge. Das heißt, man könnte alles, wo Glücksspiel drin steht, sperren. Aber du hast trotzdem noch das Problem, dass du die ganze Zeit das ganze Internet durchsuchen musst, wo irgendwo Glücksspiel stehen könnte, damit du diesen DNS-Eintrag... Wie gesagt, das Thema ist durch. Es ist bekannt, dass Web-Sperren nicht funktionieren. Umso erstaunlicher ist es, dass jetzt irgendein Binnenmarktausschuss der EU sich dazu Bedeutung verhelfen will. Da muss man also auch ein bisschen sein Auge drauf haben, weil wenn wir da nicht aufpassen, dann ist da plötzlich aus dem Nichts ein neuer Misthaufen gewachsen, um den wir uns dann nachher kümmern müssen.
Neben Prism und Überwachung und den kümmern müssen. Es gibt weiterhin viel zu tun.
Ich denke, damit sind wir am Ende. Wir bedanken uns fürs Zuhören und hören uns wieder in der nächsten Woche.